how we attached or did not attach to
primary caregivers in our childhood has
much to do with how we attach or fail to
attach to romantic Partners as adults
because the same neural circuits the
neurons and their connections in the
brain and body that underlie attachment
between infant and caregiver between
toddler and parent or other caregiver
and during adolescence and in our
teenage years are repurposed for adult
romantic attachments Okay so we've got
our four categories we've got category
one which is securely attached we've got
category two which is insecurely
attached also sometimes called anxious
avoidant then we've got category three
which is the resistant insecure category
which is anxious ambivalent and then
there's this fourth category the
disorganized disoriented category where
the so-called D babies
now what's interesting about this from
the perspective of Desire love and
attachment is that the categorizations
of children into one of these four
different categories as toddlers is
strongly predictive of their attachment
style in romantic Partnerships later in
life
which is to me both amazing and
surprising and not surprising all at the
same time amazing because it means that
uh first of all we are relatively
hardwired for attachment I think that
that's incredible and beautiful that we
have designated neurons nerve cells and
hormonal systems that are there to
ensure that we have some sort of
response to a caregiver being there or
not being there or returning or leaving
when people say relationship is hard the
only really hard part about of a good
relationship is just dealing with
oneself and making sure that you're
staying in that mode of caretaking
because I do believe that if one is
mainly focused on taking good care of
the other person provided they're also
focused on taking good care of you
to some extent and we're good at taking
care of ourselves everybody flourishes
everything gets better
there is a power dynamic in
relationships sometimes not all but in
some relationships it works much better
if one person leads and the other person
follows in other relationships it's more
mutuality works best people need to know
what they need and so knowing what you
need and what you crave is really
important and then once you do that you
can create the relationship you want
I've seen that over and over again and
people are different you have to be
careful the questions you ask in a
relationship too you have to make sure
you really want that information and
it's not just about people's past right
if you ask somebody how they really feel
about something about you and they tell
you
that may be soothing it may be intensely
stressful for a relationship to work you
have to be brave
you can't go in there fully protected
and yet you also can't go in there with
no boundaries because you'll end up beat
up what's that quote if you want to be a
warrior prepare to get hurt if you want
to be an Explorer prepared to get lost
and if you become a lover prepare to
beat both love scary because it takes us
back to that primitive circuitry that is
as primitive and basic as hunger thirst
the desire for heat when we're cold the
desire for cold when we're overly warm
the insula is a really interesting brain
area that allows us to enterocept to pay
attention to what's going on inside our
body and to split some of our attention
to exterocept and the mating dance
whether or not it's um the dinner and
date portion of the mating dance that is
a coordinated activity of two bodies
typically it's due that coordinated
dance is one in which the autonomic
nervous system of one individual
in general is coordinating with the
autonomic nervous system of the other
individual and the insula is essentially
splitting one's attention between how we
feel ourselves how our body feels what
we're thinking with the thinking and the
body's bodily sensations of the other
and that can be communicated obviously
through words I can be communicated
through sounds it can be communicated
through touch and it can be communicated
through a number of
um of kind of more subtle cues like
pupil size or whether or not
um certainly in cases where we recognize
the person and we kind of know their
responses their autonomic responses
under different conditions we can assess
it is the person comfortable are they
uncomfortable are they um are they more
focused on me or on themselves this is
the the coordinated silent dance that if
we look out in neurobiological terms we
can really see is all about the
autonomic nervous system our nervous
system is Tethered to the nervous
systems of others and that is true from
the very earliest stage of Our Lives
that is vitally important to understand
because
if one is successful in forming romantic
attachments maintaining them Etc or not
does in fact reflect the earlier
templates that you've created but as I
mentioned before the good news is that
these templates can shift over time and
one of the more powerful ways to shift
those templates over time is purely by
the knowledge that they exist and the
understanding that those templates are
malleable they can change through the
process of neuroplasticity ultimately a
relationship however one structures is
going to be part of your daily routine
so at the point where you're like you
know I'd really love to wake up next to
somebody and do blank and blank together
and then I'd love to work and then we
meet for dinner and then we you know
take the dog for a walk or take kids out
or whatever it happens to be take a trip
but do it you have to be one has to be
in the mindset of wanting to do couple
like things
there's a certain brain air it's called
the ventromedial hypothalamus this is a
brain area that's really interesting
because it has a population of neurons
that control mating you stimulate them
and animals will just start trying to
copulate with basically whatever's
around if you give them a choice of
their usual preference of you know
females if they're male
males if they're female and we have
switches right I mean we have switches
for rage switches for all these things I
mean that's like this idea that we have
all things inside of us I mean people
vary in their propensity for Rage or For
Love or for anything but at some level
we do have all things inside of us we
have the circuitry within us breakups
what's happened is the person is no
longer available in time and space this
is why when someone breaks up you
literally have to let them go right you
know constant pursuing of them is out of
context is not healthy they have a name
for that it's called a stalker don't do
it
um but it's almost as if you have to the
brain has to think that the person is
gone in time and space this has become
much harder with social media right
because people can check up on people
they can hear from people in the old
days like when I was growing up you just
like took the phone off the hook or you
diverted your attention now we are
constantly renewing that the person is
still there and so love and the loss of
love and the death grief are virtually
identical it's that motivational State
this is why it's so hard to not reach
out to somebody that you really miss and
want back
foreign